- Sherri Sager joined Lucille
Packard's Children's Hospital
at Stanford in 1994 and
she continues to serve
as the Chief Government and
Community Relations Officer.
She has more than 30 years of experience
in government having worked
as staff for elected officials
on all levels of government.
She's managed political campaigns.
Wait and talk with her
at the intermission,
as well as having served as a volunteer
on city and county task
forces and commissions.
And Sherri's title is Children's Hospitals
and the Importance of Health Insurance
and Medicaid for Children
with Disabilities
and Special Care Needs.
Welcome to the podium.
(applause)
- Thank you, I was just whispering to Lucy
that the most difficult task for me today
will be to stay on point with my slide
because I wanna work off
of what Amy was just saying
and I kept thinking of all these things
I wanted to say.
But I should let you know ahead of time,
I tend to do that.
Because I think those
are important things.
And so I'm really
grateful for the privilege
of speaking here today,
and I thank Lucy so much
for thinking of us and me and my colleague
Lisa Chamberlain who will follow.
But I wanna start before
I start my formal slides
with a couple of sort
of preliminary comments.
Way back when, when I worked for a member
of the state legislature, one of the most
organized and informed
groups were the Developmental
Disabilities Group, and
I was a District Director
for a state legislator, and they'd come in
and they'd say, teach
us all about advocacy.
How do we get some changes
because at that time,
not unlike now, state
budget was in trouble
and there were threats
to funding programs.
So I've always found the
developmentally disabled
community willing to step up to the plate,
tell their stories, share it and say
this is important to us.
You need to talk to us, you know we vote.
And if I were writing this,
I would put it in bold.
I'd highlight it and I'd underline it.
We vote, it makes a difference.
The other preliminary
comment is it's always
very discouraging to me when I'm talking
to somebody in Washington DC especially,
and they're an elected
official or they work
for an elected official
and they confuse the terms
Medicare and Medicaid.
And it happens way more than it should
since it shouldn't happen at all.
The key is Medicare is funded by all of us
who work, through payroll taxes.
Medicaid comes from the general fund.
And it is not only the
safety net for folks
who are low income, but
it is the safety net
for anyone who has high
medical bills with the idea
that you don't go broke
because of high medical costs.
So part of my job is stereotype breaking.
I won't let people get away with saying
oh those poor people,
they're just on welfare
and they don't do anything to deserve it.
That's baloney.
And part of what we
have to do is put a face
on who's on Medicaid or
in California, MediCal.
The one other point I would
make is that the formula,
Amy went through and talked
to you about the formula
and the FMAP, it's an antiquated formula.
But we can't change it.
It's antiquated because it's based
on both the state's poverty level
and a per capita.
Well California has one of the highest
poverty rates in the country.
So you would think that our rate would be
so much higher.
Well we have a little
problem in that we've got
the Bay area.
More specifically we've got Silicon Valley
and San Francisco, drives
up the per capita income
for the entire state.
So while we have one of
the highest poverty rates,
we also have the highest per capita,
which keeps us at that 50%.
It's problematic but we're never gonna get
that changed unfortunately
because there are
more states than us and
they have the votes.
The other big difference between Medicare
and Medicaid and it comes
in here, is that Medicare
is a federal program that
says here are all the things
you have to do.
It may be implemented on
a state-by-state basis
or a region, but there are
clear federal guidelines.
It is a federal program.
Medicaid has a federal umbrella who says
you have to do these kinds of things
but beyond that, you can do what you want
and it's really, thank
you, as I lose my voice.
Which is probably not a bad thing.
There are 54 different Medicaid programs
in the country.
One Medicare program,
54 Medicaid programs.
It makes a huge difference
when you're trying
to advocate, when you're
trying to make changes,
when you're trying to protect the program.
But neither Lisa or I
have anything to disclose.
And so I wanna talk more deeply about
who are the children that are covered
by Medicare and CHIP?
CHIP stands for the Children's
Health Insurance Program
and when congress first
passed CHIP they said,
okay, we've taken care of kids.
We don't have to worry about that anymore.
Let's move on.
Mm, not quite true.
Almost half of the children
with special healthcare needs
are covered by either Medicare and CHIP
and in 2008, the last
recession with a big R
in California, we
combined the CHIP program
into the MediCal program.
So even within our MediCal
program in California,
we have two different FMAPs.
Because the kids on CHIP,
it's a 65-35% match.
So the federal government
pays 65% of the cost.
The state pays 35%.
But it's all blended together to create
our Medicaid program.
As each day is different,
so the cost or share
of children with special
healthcare needs can vary
from 23% to 67%.
You heard Amy say they might
have all the eligibility
requirements but they cap
how much the funding is
so that limits.
I talked to my colleagues
at Texas Children's
all the time who are
lamenting that the state's
already run out of money and there's kids
on waiting lists who are eligible
but the state has no money.
75% of Medicaid CHIP children with special
healthcare needs live
in families below 200%
of the federal poverty level.
The federal poverty
level is roughly $16,000
for a family of three.
So you're talking about $32,000.
I don't know that you are
surviving very well anywhere
in the state of California,
but definitely not
in the bay area.
This is Tyler.
Tyler's one of my advocates.
I took Tyler back to Washington DC with me
two years ago when he was four.
He's now six.
And when I called mom,
'cause I actually have
written permission and I called mom to say
is it okay if, I'm doing this conference,
I wanna show the pictures
from DC and with Tyler
and show his care map, which you'll see
in a little bit.
She said here, let me give
you his updated photo.
So I think it's okay for
me to talk about Tyler.
Tyler was born with half a heart.
And his parents were told he
had, they had two options.
They could bring him home.
He was 32 hours old at this point,
and they could bring
him home and say goodbye
or they could have him
airlifted to Packard.
Now this is a family
that plans everything.
They dated for a long time and say okay,
we've saved up money, we can get married.
They got married.
Saved up money said okay,
we could buy our house.
They bought their house.
Saved up money and said okay,
we could start our family,
started our family.
And they did something
that most of us don't
even think about.
They bought helicopter
insurance, life flight insurance
in their health plan.
'Cause you know, just never know.
(laughter)
And then mom went into labor prematurely.
Tyler was born, that was their option.
They said life flight him to Packard.
He got to Packard before,
well mom was still
in the hospital, before dad got there.
He was already into surgery
before dad even got there.
Turns out though their
helicopter insurance
was for the wrong helicopter company.
And so it didn't cover.
But we take care of things like that.
It's one of the things
that children's hospitals
tend to do.
And we don't want families
to go broke either.
And so we actually, through
our financial counseling,
took care of it.
And I have to tell you
this family also has
primary health insurance
through dad's job,
secondary health insurance
through mom's job
and Medicaid to cover all
of the ancillary services
and wrap around services.
They could not survive without that.
Dad makes choices about where he works
because of the health insurance.
So he makes the commute from Scotts Valley
to San Jose every day
in order to make sure
that Tyler gets the
coverage that Tyler needs.
For me, that's a red
flag, something we need
to do something about.
That's not okay.
They should be just able to
focus on doing the right thing
for their family and
having dad working closer
to home would sure help a lot.
So what are the demographics?
Who are the kids who
are on Medicaid or CHIP
and have special healthcare needs?
Well, 7% of them have
incomes that are 400%
of the federal poverty level.
This is throughout the US,
so it's not just California.
43% are less than 100% of
the federal poverty level.
As any of you who work
with or are somebody
with a developmental disability, you know
that it's hard to hold
down a full-time job
even when you want to,
whether you're a caretaker,
caregiver, it's just tough to do that.
And we don't make it any easier.
So it's really important that we continue
to be able to provide Medicaid
so that at least families
know that they have health coverage.
Their race, ethnicity, 40%
are non-Hispanic white.
29% are Hispanic.
22% are non-Hispanic African American.
So if you start looking
at how our population
in the country breaks down,
this is pretty similar.
So again, we're gonna bust a stereotype.
It's not all people of color.
It is everyone.
It can hit anyone's family.
Now we're gonna start
seeing this age change.
It used to be you had a lot higher numbers
of the zero to five, higher percentages,
and then as they got
older, they got smaller
the percentages.
Well one of the good things
is that through medical
research and technology,
we're saving, not only
are we saving a lot of
children and families,
but we're giving them a quality of life.
Because we often hear, oh
well there's an ethical issue.
You know you're saving these children
but now there's this huge cost to society
for taking care of them.
Well guess what, when we
save children's lives,
when we give them a productive life,
they give back and we get those back
in all sorts of ways.
So it's a good thing to be doing,
but it changes our age breakdown.
The other myth is, oh,
all this money's going
to all these kids.
Two-thirds of Medicaid
spending is for elderly
and then people with disabilities.
And a lot of the elderly
who have disabilities
and if they're low income, they qualify.
You hear them referred to as medi medi's.
They have Medicare and Medicaid.
So Medicaid covers their
premiums and other services
that are not covered by Medicare.
It makes a difference.
Children are 43%.
We usually add in pregnant
women 'cause they're covered
if they're low income by Medicaid as well.
And as a children's
hospital that actually has
a pretty robust labor and delivery,
we're as interested in that number.
So about 50% of the people on Medicaid
are women and children.
And most of those children
are healthy children.
And there's some children in
the disabled bucket as well.
The expenditures, this
is the one that's key.
Only 19% of expenditures go to children.
40% of the Medicaid
expenditures go to folks
who are disabled.
So what does Medicaid mean for children?
Medicaid and CHIP, it
benefits the entire family,
not just the child.
It provides access to care.
They're cost-effective programs.
When children are healthy,
they're less likely
to miss school.
They're healthier into adulthood.
They can earn higher wages.
And then guess what?
They can pay more taxes
and keep the cycles going.
I'm doing a lot of work these days
on adolescent mental health.
And I have a lot of frustration
because everybody wants
to solve the folks who
are mentally ill coming in
to the emergency rooms, and
I'm like that's important
but if we would put some money into kids
and into prevention, we might be able
to reduce those costs
when they get to adulthood
because we will have solved the issue.
And let's put more
dollars into prevention,
into caring for children and teens,
whether it's physical
health and mental health
and please, please, please,
please, let's get rid
of the silos.
Let's encourage integrated healthcare.
It's better for everyone.
Medicaid enables low-income
children to receive
that needed care without co
payments and deductibles.
I often hear people say, and legislators
or legislative staff saying
well if people would buy
into the system, you know a co-pay, $50,
it's no big deal.
I wanted to ask them if they
would spend a week living
either as someone with a disability
or on a limited budget that
would qualify for Medicaid
and then tell me that $50 is no big deal.
I want them to have to make that decision.
I have $50, my kid's healthy
this week, this month.
Do I pay for a health
premium that we don't need?
Do I make a rent payment or do I buy food
for my kids?
I could tell you which
one comes out on bottom.
It's an inexpensive way to cover children.
And when parents are
covered, which is what
the Affordable Care Act allowed us to do,
children are more likely to receive
the preventative healthcare.
Because parents and kids
are doing this together.
And it increases access to prenatal care
which reduces infant
mortality and morbidity
and we saw it with the passage
of the Affordable Care
Act for three years,
from 2014 til last year, we
were seeing those numbers.
And then as Lisa knows,
Dr. Chamberlain knows,
my favorite sentence is
Medicaid is the underpinning
of the entire healthcare
system for children.
And I wanna repeat that.
Medicaid is the underpinning
for the entire healthcare
system for children.
That means (laughs) thanks Lucy.
See, she's always being a caregiver.
I don't care how much money you make,
how good your health insurance is,
if your children's
hospital, whether it's part
of a large system like the UCs or part
of a independent non-profit like Packard,
if we haven't been able to
hire the right specialist,
one because they are few and far between,
or two because we don't have enough volume
to guarantee that they have an expertise,
not only is that care
not there for a child
on Medicaid, that care
isn't there for any child.
So to have a healthy
children's health system,
you need Medicaid.
Volume equals expertise.
There is a reason why, and
I hope that anybody here
at UCSF doesn't take offense,
but there is a reason
why Packard is the number one
pediatric transplant program
in the country.
It's because it's able to have the volume
and it takes care of children on Medicaid
from multiple states.
What Medicaid means for
children's hospitals is
that children's hospitals by in large see
more Medicaid patients
that the vast majority
of other hospitals.
Your first response is gonna say, oh,
I don't think so Sherri.
What about those public hospitals?
You've got public hospitals
all through the state.
They take care of low-income children
and they take care of Medicaid.
You're right, they do.
And they take care of Medicare,
and they take care of uninsured.
And when you look at the percentage
of Medicaid, it's actually
higher in children's hospitals.
Because we don't take care of Medicare.
So Packard is on the low end.
We're only 43% Medicaid.
Children's Hospital
Los Angeles is hovering
between 75 and 80% as is
Children's Hospital Oakland
or now as it's known UCSF Benioff Oakland.
Valley Children's
Hospital, the same thing.
So Medicaid is really the foundation
and when you cut Medicaid,
there isn't anyplace to go.
And what this does as I said is it allows
for that much-needed pediatric expertise.
It's also the foundation
of financial sustainability
for children's hospitals.
We depend on those supplemental programs
what again, if you're a
public hospital is called DSH,
disproportionate share,
but for private hospitals
and children's hospitals, it's
called supplemental payment
or its DSH lookalike.
It's identical rules to qualify for DSH.
It's just not called DSH
because of funding streams
which is all back of the room.
Graduate medical education,
the provider fee.
Sometimes adult hospitals get really upset
because children's hospitals
get the biggest proportion
of the provider fee in
the state of California.
Well there are two reasons.
We have the most beds covered by Medicaid
and we hay the highest provider taxes.
So the formula is, you get back based
on how many MediCal patients you serve
and what the utilization is.
I can tell you for Packard,
that's about $65 million
a year, the provider fee.
We don't qualify for DSH.
We're in the absolute worst
place you could possibly be.
We missed qualifying by about 1%.
Missing by 1% costs us $10 million.
But it is what it is.
So we are very dependent and appreciative
of the provider fee.
Some of my colleagues are
at children's hospitals
where they're receiving
hundreds of millions of dollars
and it literally is the
only way they're able
to keep programs operating.
And people say, well but it's a tax.
So we should cut all taxes.
This is a tax that we, I'm not
sure gladly is the right term
but we gladly pay ourselves
and have voted ourselves
to self tax ourselves in order to be able
to draw down these federal
dollars because these are dollars
that the state of California
was leaving on the table.
California was eligible
for these dollars based
on the federal government's formula,
but there wasn't enough money
in the state general fund
to be able to draw the dollars down.
So by taxing ourselves as hospitals,
we give that money to the state to be able
to bring those dollars down
from the federal government.
So don't let anyone tell you
that California is getting
more than its fair share.
It's not, and California even with this,
is still a donor state to
the federal government.
And I wanted to tie it in,
because I can't do a presentation
like this without at least touching
on the Affordable Care
Act, and then I will try
to wrap it up so I leave enough time
for Dr. Chamberlain, because
the Affordable Care Act,
especially for kids and
especially for folks
with disabilities is a life saver.
It means no annual caps, no lifetime caps,
and you couldn't be discriminated on with
buying health insurance
because of that disability.
That was important.
It's important to our
patients, and we will continue
to strongly advocate for that.
The future of Medicaid, the challenges,
Amy touched on some.
There will be attempts
to continue to repeal all
of the Affordable Care Act, especially
the Medicaid expansions, to
cut eligibility requirements,
to cut benefits.
Make no mistake, if you do block grants
or per capita, it's cutting funding
because then they put it in a block grant,
they don't see anybody's
face, and then they cut.
And most serious again, is a
non-realistic understanding
of what Medicaid is and
does by a significant number
of elected and appointed officials.
So I talked about Tyler.
This is Tyler's care
map, and mom said she has
to get me an updated
one because they've got
more appointments than this now.
For him to go back to DC with me, he had
to get approval from 18
different pediatric specialists.
And he had to bring his oxygen and we had
to have backup batteries for his oxygen
on the airplane.
And this is Tyler talking
to Congresswoman Anna Eshoo
and showing her that above all else,
he is a kid, and he is a child
just like any other child.
Thank you.
(applause)
- That was great.
After all these years I
understand Medicaid and Medicare
and all of that, thank you.
Or at least understand it better.
Why do they wanna do away with it, uh.
So our next speaker, also from Stanford
but previously with UCSF, where she was
in fellowship in a joint
UCSF Stanford program
and I had the opportunity to
work with Lisa Chamberlain
on a number of advocacy
projects including things
that we did with the Academy of Pediatrics
in establishing the
California Advocacy Committee
that involves all of
the residency programs
throughout our state.
But that's not what she's
gonna be talking about today.
So let's get back to basics,
and Lisa will continue
to enlighten us on the
importance of health insurance
and Medicaid for children
with disabilities
and special healthcare needs.
Welcome to the podium Dr. Chamberlain.
(applause)
- Good morning, thank you
very much for the invitation.
And I need to say that
this is kind of coming
full circle for me because I would not
be able to do the work that I'm about
to share with you that I
do without the two women
in this room, Lucy Crane and Sherri Sager.
As a resident, I was so
overwhelmed with I saw
taking care of these kids and frustrated
that I couldn't get kids
that I cared for eyeglasses.
It was actually a 17-year-old girl
who I'd taken care of for a long time,
a real bright, bilingual,
bi cultural immigrant girl
who came to my clinic with headaches,
and headaches that were
worse at the end of the day.
This is a kid who had straight As.
She was awesome.
And headaches at the ends of
the day, probably squinting.
That's the first thing
you do, check her vision.
Sure enough, she needs glasses.
And this was the day before
the Healthy Kids Program,
and I could not get her glasses.
That's what she needed,
a pair of eyeglasses.
I spent months trying to figure out.
Because all she had was
EPSDT which meant she
could be seen on intervals to be cared for
but she was out of interval.
And I called the Lion's Club,
and they had a waiting list,
and I spent my own time
calling different providers.
I finally found someone in Burlingame.
And I remember the day I called her.
I was so excited.
I found an optometrist
that's gonna get you glasses.
And she was like, oh okay, where is it?
I said, Burlingame.
And she said, oh, how will
I ever get to Burlingame,
'cause she was down with
us in East Palo Alto.
And I just remember, so
overwhelmed and feeling
like how can I practice medicine.
How can I do this?
I know I'm drawn to care
for underserved patients
but how can I do this and
not completely burn out.
Because as physicians we
inherit failed social policy.
It was a failed social policy that put me
in that situation.
And there was no way I
could sustainably practice
and care for this
population unless I started
to figure out how to change these policies
and get activated around that.
And that's been a bit part of my career
and what I'm gonna talk to
about in our last 15 minutes
for this session.
But medical school had not
prepared me to do that.
Not even slightly.
I went to Berkeley and
got a public health degree
because I knew I needed those skills,
and then I was graced with Sherri Sager
and Lucy Crane coming
into my life, both of whom
took me to Sacramento.
I spent many, many evenings
in Lucy's living room
planning and strategizing
and building capacity
in pediatrics to address the policies
that create the problems.
So I'm not gonna show you any statistics.
Like I've learned a lot just listening
and I thought I knew a lot about Medicaid,
but I'm gonna tell stories
about how we are working
in pediatrics and how I hope we can start
creating trans disciplinary
action together
with other fields to improve
the health of children.
So the story I wanna tell
first is what happened
in the fall of 2016.
So we'd come through
an interesting election
and we're hit with a series of headlines
that threatened a lot
of what we care about,
headlines around repealing the ACA
and changes around immigration policy.
And the pediatric residents
that I work with at Stanford
came to me an said we are really worried
about our families.
We are hearing from our
families that they are scared,
that they don't want to come to clinic,
that they're gonna lose
their healthcare coverage.
What could we do about this?
And part of my job there is to talk about
the social determinants of health
and to teach them about health policy.
And so I said well, I
don't know, let's think.
Let's throw it open.
We got to talk to Sherri.
So that's my first call all the time.
And she said well why
don't we have a town hall.
So we opened up a town hall and not just
to our physicians at
Packard but to all staff.
Emails went out to everyone
saying if you're concerned
about the changing kind
of prevailing wisdom
coming from the east coast
right now, come talk to us.
And so we held a town hall, and had three
quick presentations on the
changes around Medicaid,
around immigration and about funding
for pediatric research.
And then just opened it up and said what,
it was a group about this size,
said what do you guys want
to do about it.
You're people who came
out on a whatever it was,
Tuesday night, to talk about this.
What are you interested in?
And we brainstormed
together for about an hour.
And this group of people
said what we want to do
is have a strong, coherent voice together
to fight for our families
and to fight for our kids.
And that was the beginning of what we call
our Policy Response Team that now exists
down at Packard.
And we kinda came together
and had two main goals.
One was to organize and
strengthen our local
professional community
so that we could better
advocate together in a
real time sensitive way
when different issues came forward.
And we also wanted to educate ourselves.
We wanted to educate the next generation
of pediatricians as well
as everyone around us
about the important
impact that these things
were having on our families.
So over the last year
and a half we've taken
a lot of action together.
You can see some signs here
around different issues,
DACA and CHIP being a couple big ones.
And the ways we've done that,
a lot of teaching sessions.
So we went from having a
couple policy updates a year
to closer to 12.
So almost every month we're
having a different topic
and teaching the residents
about these issues.
And then the importance
of letting, we said,
go into those town halls.
Our legislators come home.
They have town halls,
and we not only have them
on our calendar, we send
emails out to everyone,
there's a town hall, who can go.
Who wants to go together?
Let's carpool, let's get down there.
And you can see we wear our white coats.
We stand up.
We talk about kids.
We talk about the
importance of these issues.
Sometimes when it's Anna Eshoo's town hall
for instance, we thank her.
Thank you for being a
champion for children.
We appreciate that.
You have to shore up those
who are your champions
in Washington and who
consistently are a voice
for the families that we care about.
And it's interesting, when you stand up
and talk at these things,
the media follow you out
and say excuse me, excuse
me, can we get a quote?
And so our residents
and our faculty have had
many opportunities to talk and get our
voice out even further.
And one thing I've noticed,
I think it can feel
intimidating to go by yourself.
This idea of I'm gonna look it up,
and I'm gonna go and I'm
gonna speak to people.
But as a group, people seem to love it.
Like okay, who can go
this Saturday afternoon
and we'll all go grab
lunch and we'll think
about what's happening, and then lets
just all go together.
And if it's your first one,
you can just sit there.
You don't have to say anything.
You know so this idea I
think that we're not alone.
We're in this together and we really need
to start getting more organized I think
in working together with this.
And we would certainly
welcome our colleagues
who are again, in different
fields, joining us on these.
Because I think we can all
tell those powerful stories.
We are getting very organized
about letter writing.
We have lots of opportunities.
Every single teaching
conference that we do
is accompanied by an opportunity
to send letters, to tweet.
I'm gonna get to that in a minute.
To get our voices out,
to make phone calls.
But the letter writing,
if for instance we have
a grand rounds that has a policy angle,
we had one recently on the
increasing price of insulin
and just how crazy that
is, what's going on.
And so where there's something that again
that failed social policy
that we are all inheriting,
we have out, kind of
like where we signed in
and got our badges, at
grand rounds we have
a similar table.
There are letters out there
to make it easy for you.
Grab one of these.
Take it in, write it while
you're sitting in grand rounds.
Drop it off at the end or do it at the end
and we'll get that sent for you.
So just putting it in front of people.
Operationalizing, we could
have an advocacy letter today,
right, we could take advantage of the time
that we're together to
raise our voice together,
make it easy for people to address
these policy issues.
We've coordinated greatly with the
American Academy of
Pediatrics where Lucy was
enormous leadership role for many years
to raise our voice even more broadly
and to coordinate things nationally.
So one of our opportunities in California
and Lucy eluded to it is that years ago
we built a collaboration
between the 14 training programs
in California, and I did that with Lucy,
with Dr. Andequo and
Gina Lewis, both up here,
and reached out to the
other training programs
and said hey we really could
have a much more powerful
voice in Sacramento if
we organized ourselves
and if we spoke together in
a much more coherent way.
And so we've reached out
on these American Academy
of Pediatric days of
action because that kind of
is an umbrella across all of our campuses.
We're all parts of the AAP.
And so we take action when they have days
to take action together, we make sure
that every single program in
California is participating,
and the voice roaring out of California
has not been small I'm very proud to say.
And because of all this, I'm
not a social media person
my daughters will tell you, I'm hopeless.
But I have joined Twitter.
And it is a part of my job.
It is a really important way to advocate.
And I asked Lucy, I said
what's your Twitter handle
for this meeting.
Because I took pictures of
Lucy and Amy standing after.
I would be tweeting about this.
And people across the
country who follow me
would be hearing about this.
I've wanted to thank
Kaiser for that great slide
I used, that slide you used all the time.
I was gonna write, I
already know the tweet
I'm gonna send, thank you
@Kaiser Family Foundation,
you know we continue to use your site.
But Kaiser will see that.
There's somebody at Kaiser
watching that today,
their Twitter feed.
It is a really powerful way,
and this is the very first
tweet I sent up there on top.
It says #Firsttweet, so your first tweet
is always followed.
But it's interesting because
at the morning conference
and we were getting the residents ready
to do this Twitter storm, I said okay,
everyone get out and log on to Twitter.
And they all looked at me.
And I'm like, you are
all on Twitter, right?
And they're like, no.
(laughter)
and I was like oh my, really?
And they're all on Instagram and Snapchat,
which I'm aware of because
I have teenage daughters.
And they're like, Twitter's
like for grown ups.
(laughter)
Which explains why I like
it and I'm not on Snapchat
and Instagram.
It is actually work.
The people on Twitter
are having conversations
about policy, about guns, about taxes.
It is not social in the same way
that I had thought of the Facebooks
and everything else.
This I really have shifted
in the last six months.
This is a part of my job.
It is my job to get it out there.
It is my job to stay on for it.
And the people who make decisions listen
to this conversation.
And that's why we have to be on it.
So I would encourage you, maybe set a goal
to at least talk to someone
about getting on Twitter.
It's really not hard at all.
I was surprised.
So as an example of the power of Twitter,
the American Academy had
a day of Stand for CHIP
because we were just so
unbelievably frustrated
with that situation.
Took a lot of action that day.
We had good media coverage,
not just at Packard
but across the state.
And here are the numbers.
We used two different hashtags.
It's kinda how Twitter
organizes their conversations.
So one hashtag was #DontCapMyCare.
It had about 6,000 posts
snatched nationally
which means we reached four
million individual people.
#KeepKidsCovered was the
other hashtag we used.
8,000 posts, almost nine million people.
And having spent two
years working part time
in Sacramento 'cause
I wanted to understand
this policy better, I
can tell you the staffers
who report directly to the legislators
sit in front of screens
with the Twitter feed
over here, and they watch
what's called trending.
What's trending?
What's everyone talking about?
What is this?
What is this don't cap my care?
What is this keep kids covered?
And they will click
through and they will look
at our conversation.
So on both on this day when we did this,
we trended all day long.
We know we reached every
single staffer on the hill
with these messages that day.
And that's why this is important.
That's why this matters.
Because of this, because
our residents have just been
unbelievably inspiring,
Sherri asked if she
could take them to Washington with her
on one of her trips.
There's a couple of them over
here on right, Lee and Jen.
So they got to go to
Washington, walk the halls
with Sherri, which is
where I got my education.
So it was real pleased that
they were able to do that.
We've also created a story
bank because the power
of stories is so
important and what this is
is a secure Google doc in our hospital
that our residents and
others if they have stories
if they are feeling
frustrated and they want
to put their story down they can.
Here's one somebody put in.
"A mother of two school-age
children with terrible oral
"sores was afraid to come to the doctor
"or the emergency room because she has
"an electronic bracelet is
worried about getting deported.
"She was so scared to
come in that by the time
"they arrived, both children
were severely dehydrated."
So we get stories all the time.
It is a way for the physicians
and the caregivers to vent,
to put their story down, to
share what they're seeing.
We have tons and tons and daily examples
of people delaying coming in because
of fear of immigration.
We have people who
delayed, the worst is a kid
who got delayed getting a
really important diagnosis
that probably changed his course.
And so Sherri takes these stories
and she takes them to
Washington and she shares them.
And she says this is what's happening.
So we take that voice and we take it right
to our policy makers.
So the story bank has been something
that's been both therapeutic I think
and effective as an advocacy tool.
So how did we do this?
We got ourselves organized,
incredible support
from our institution.
And no matter where you work
I just would encourage you
to try to do something similar.
We have great support
from our CEO across the,
without question he supports us.
We send out weekly emails to everyone
on our Policy Response Team each week
to tell them kinda what's going on.
Here's the update from DC, et cetera.
Here's how you can take action.
We have these meetings.
We use an app called Slack
to keep ourselves organized.
Sherri hates it but it
does work, I promise.
And I think going forward
this could really be
more powerful in an interdisciplinary way.
And that's what I'm excited
to be here about today,
to join forces with other voices,
with our parents and our patients.
Because I think at that point we really
would be unstoppable.
And I'll just finish to say that quickly,
this is something that
I've been working on
for about the last 10 years
building things in California.
There's the original group in California
and just a shot there of
how we are in Sacramento.
We'll be in Sacramento mid
April, taking our voices.
But we're also, this
model of coming together
across the state is something
that's kinda caught on
and it's been really fun.
I'm now leading different
statewide collaboratives
in other places and
different academic programs
from across states are coming together
to build their voice.
And so right now we have collaboratives
in California, Missouri,
North and South Carolina
and New York.
I was just in Illinois last week.
They're getting on board.
New Jersey's actually already
started and next up is Texas.
These are the states that are interested.
And so the vision by 2020
is that we will have 114
out of about the 200 training programs
in the United States advocating in the way
that I've shown you that
we're doing in California.
Because unless we engage in the policy,
we are not going to be
able to really stand
and care for our children in the way
that we know that we can.
So I invite you all, if
this kinda sparked anything,
to please reach out.
Medicaid, as Amy and Sherri
have said, is so vital.
It's super important for
children with medical complexity
and we are really at an
all hands on deck moment.
It's time to unify and speak up for kids.
So this is how you can reach Sherri and I,
as well as if you're on Twitter, yay.
You can follow us.
And thank you again so much, not just
for the invitation but for about 20 years
of mentoring me, Lucy and Sherri
and happy to take any questions
that you all might have.